so when you're doing development and
you're buying land to build houses to
then sell them or we finance them
probably the most important contact is a
builder's team so we're just spending
the day right now going around different
sides getting to know Nick who's got a
great building team he's been doing this
for 27 years and looking at these
projects seeing the standard living
finish standard getting to know him as a
person and at the end of the day we can
have a coffee and hopefully we're going
to be talking joint ventures and we'll
see if we can pull out the back hey
how's it going buddy it's beautiful like
it yeah absolutely
I like this - these door are these like
folding doors dude you got it man that's
how you got to do it what's the point of
having doors that don't open all the way
oh man it's lovely so how much is it
your project than this always so how
much did you how much did you buy the
old okay to build this and then and then
what how much did they buy the old
property for would you remember or not
and what joking this would be worth once
it's done we're like jeez
[Applause]
but talking like that carnival in
Doncaster is it's just a beautiful spot
it's gonna be it's gonna be how much you
buy for 22 and a half what in Doncaster
insane how much upon what you spend on
them which no it's good yeah we've got
some we're building some properties in
Lincoln does Anika's or yeah yeah that's
because I'm new to the whole house
building side of things
yeah and smashing down and really happen
turning into a 91 is its
it's fine isn't it think it's because I
like get a bad rep sometimes because
people think are you buying all these
houses you know there's only there's
only so many houses to go around but
when you wait huh no but wait but but
the thing is though people think you
know from a position of you know we've
got a shortage of houses overpopulation
of people if I'm Nicky in all the houses
it's gonna make it difficult for
first-time buyers which I get to some
extent but the thing is when you're
building houses no one can own can moan
about that because then you actually you
actually bring them more bring you more
from the market or all restoring houses
taking absolutely rundown crapples
have you seen that castle that we're
doing yeah yeah that's going really well
we're spending a couple of million on
that but like restoring restoring
projects you know no one can really you
can't be company can't be a bad guy
doing that so how many on your team then
your builders and stuff yeah yeah so I'm
gonna job in your team right we're in
the stairs going to go and how they're
gonna look most of what comes tears with
yeah nice so then you're not space yeah
if you have spindles you'd you would I'm
just gonna it's gonna keep that real
open-air we sort of feel our great I
[Applause]
love the black and the why it's so
modern
yeah and even the windows I love the
black and the white feel so in this case
then ah yeah so in this case then your
customer is building it to living is
that right so he doesn't mind so much
about how much he bought it for not
there because he's just living in it if
you're living in it doesn't matter spend
whatever you want it's a gorgeous view
absolutely amazing you have made the
most of it because if it wasn't for all
the windows and the way you've done it
you'd been missing that it would be just
completely wasted this is a personal
thing isn't it yeah love it I think the
plan the plan is we obviously we've got
this house in Doncaster deny what warms
warms worth Road which it'd be great to
get you to come out and have a look at
turning it into apartments but also you
know we're wanting to buy land and build
and things like that
so it also pretend to go with maybe grab
a coffee or something and have a chat
about doing some kind of a joint venture
or you know if you
with your brains like every business
literally we're gonna cast as well than
the cool yeah yeah yeah when it comes to
rent it's like we're pretty good man we
really know window stuff but we you know
have a chat anyway and see I think
probably will probably go to the house
first you reckon hall yeah a new one we
chat we can also talk about the house
and yeah might as well it's only what 10
minutes down the road well look we're
here man
we'll see okay yeah well have a look
what we're here okay okay
cool sounds good so when Nick said
decent you got for coffee now and have a
chat I've really want a coffee right now
I've had a long journey I need the
toilet I want to drink but the thing is
I want to speak to him after we've seen
all the projects because I think they'll
have a much better conversation once
we've seen Moulton in the houses and
then but bother told me have a coffee
will be time to talk business
my goodness can you believe that this is
Doncaster look at this I'll be oh my
goodness
this is not Doncaster is this Doncaster
Don cash is a good investment area the
great thing about these builders is that
they're actually investors as well so
we're just going around one of the HMOs
now that I've just bought and then in
the process of doing up I think it's a
10 bed he said how many beds is this six
still good so in fact six six is the
perfect number because when you go more
than six you need piling permission so
66 is quite a good number for HMOs say
let's have a look around and see what
kind of see what I can pair does are
doing Wow
starting from scratch this is this is
like the HMOs back in the day that my
abilities to do it's a real builders
build at HMO this and it
it's gonna be amazing though this is a
[Music]
single by jesus low vision it's not as
high as you million pound house ceiling
without an ensuite I would say you're
talking about seventy five eighty pound
and then I think women ensuite you
probably talking not in pound a week
yeah to a good standard hundred pound a
week maybe it was like a palace
interesting right good guys so so we've
seen their house build projects from
scratch it's in the HMOs seem like
decent guys of course you don't know at
this point but they seem nice enough
they doing some joint ventures with
people that I know so let's grab some
lunch
see I'm gonna make them give me a
proposal I think and I'll just say I've
got money I've got experience I'm not
from the area you're builders I'm not
make me a proposal I'll put the money in
you do the work what I'm thinking it's
something like if we do it if we do a
house build from scratch say we buy
piece of land build some houses of it
what I'm thinking is I'll let them find
the land or buy it they can then do the
build at cost and then we'll come up
with some kind of a profit share on the
one of the projects that sort of what
I'm thinking let them project manage it
let them find to let them do everything
I'll fund it as long as they build for
me at cost and their incentive us to
make it really profitable because
they've got they're gonna get a
percentage of the profits that's what
what I'm thinking but I guess it also
depends on what's around here so let's
say but you'll get to hear exactly
exactly what I say exactly how I because
because the thing is you can watch all
day long the actual building take place
but if you don't know how to finance it
or find that
in the first place see if I wanted to
I've got money I could put the money in
no problem but if I've got this contact
if I find the Builder and they're
finding the projects and doing all the
work and I haven't got the money then I
could just go and find an investor and
bring the two together and take a slice
of the pie there's there's so much money
to be made in this business you only
need to slice of the pie
a slice of many pies the that's when you
get rich Gaskill so we just leverage
someone else's money basically yes
obviously we get into bill castle we're
typically building stuff for general of
people at many different levels suspect
anything for a thousand fifty just been
to a kid there's a bit different into
yes obviously more domestic and more
startups the different price but yeah
we're able to obviously do a cost in it
because our in game is to do development
for timings there's money there there's
serious amenity good money there the
serious amount money okay what we term
well at minute we Jonathan is he's
putting in the money for the deposits
because all at minute I I want to James
Jerry punch joint venture partner far
was literally if we need the deposits
someone else to go yeah let's roll there
because our sick of scenes to fall time
I'm not even up to copyright yeah and
that's just more anointing in the world
makes things happen around see we would
probably just we wouldn't get movies and
stuff we probably do all cash cheap
enough that mean it's exactly on the
stretching is an is literally the London
we're doing I'll give you a bit about
what we do in Lincoln and I love this
austere so the land we've walked for how
much was 330 yeah was 3:00 3:30 war
lambda trillion boob freedom 30 palaces
we got planning permission we bought it
subjects objective planning yeah we've
got all kind of motion approved for six
houses
the houses are going to cost us all
familiar and that's including
continually seen everything
yeah six hours watch your bill cost it
there no it put forward good yeah
8:30 all together and what square foot
are these houses seems cheap that 500
gram like for six thousand what sort of
yeah yeah yeah yeah so there's gonna be
a block of three in a little box right
yeah and they're quite small houses yeah
too bad little townhouses
six yes before about doing timber-framed
yeah is timber frame timber frame we're
bricks skin on the outside so it is
brick bricks on the outside so I don't
know it's basically what happens is you
get it done quicker because all your
trades are inside well you're on the
outside doing that as that
that one's a traditional build with
bricks on outside those on inside yeah
so they are better to trade and next
week this week they're putting all the
timber frames are yeah and they've said
it will take between six and nine months
yet of the whole thing completely
finished yeah we've had a Rix valuer
decide that the end value means that
we've got for many runs from yeah
they're four years what forward now what
I've done right because I'm not hands
off but I've got money is all I have got
a part that the fit the part of the
building team we're giving them a profit
share yeah and we just say goodnight but
they found the loans yeah yeah if we
think I haven't do a thing all I do is
go there walks away from the heart
do a YouTube video yeah yeah that's why
I like it so so I've said because they
found the land they've done everything
they've sorted the planning they fought
absolutely everything I've said that I'm
gonna give him 25 percent profit share
so when it's all done any profit that we
make they're going to be rather than me
making more familiar and I'm not late
for my friends yeah and feel a thing
sounds feeling too well but we made over
a million last month to go there are
trying to business construction business
because we also move letting agency we
other sort property sort of some
business we have obviously investment so
we've got a lot of things well yeah yeah
you systemize it good enough no means
such homeland business something you've
gotta get your systems of blades
properly the thing is that all my
business is really well you all seen
opportunities all day every day don't
caster and you know we think about this
yeah and no one's willing to keep going
I'm from nobody yeah everybody runs out
I'm gonna I mean the like I lost a film
we're not I'm gonna it's like you're
like get to the battle phase right
you're gonna mean because you can always
think about a next investment that next
deal you know that mean so you like
refine lines and stuff things like
there's always me without all / didn't
know that's what we said didn't we got
some point where we look we've seen all
this cool stuff we just need to be able
to finish it so that's why we wrote that
don't venture bitter than it stead of
losing out and they'll get a bit reality
we can still all move forward can't win
game get get a boy buy to cook regards
contracts and stuff who did you get or
what we go with jonatha cuz I'm just
thinking if you like well Jonathan it's
pretty simple because honestly
he's probably getting a veteran deal so
best but all we're gonna sell but SBV is
okay we're all like individual share
orders direct or in their money number
so doing Mike honestly accomplished
obviously a injection in force yeah
we're doing same on our end so they're
paying for the brief we're doing to Lisa
put some money together yeah that's it
yeah right and how move the shares do
you know how you yeah yeah we should got
25 cent chairs piece it's for tartness
or partners there's a bit you to boost
to a partner's we've got 25 percent
shares each fall then you have John's
share partner you know Johnson and Paul
stone yeah it's working into we find him
so we've got a few investors now on for
that yeah
when you know the money's it's hard to
find the deals I could potentially bring
to you guys as well
yeah rather than just me as and don't
mess upon them yeah would be like other
joint venture partners because I've got
ya know we run the largest property
train company in the UK right every week
we do it we do it we do a crash course
but now that supposed to get thousand
people cool like we're mega you know you
know why I'm on the train inside but
we've got a very very large following
and stuff so potentially we could put
you in front of other people if what we
be were yeah yeah it's all because I
think is I want me personally I'm not an
introvert but I I'm still very lie I
have to qualify people the only me I
have to trust people and still there and
I won't just go out do some of us do it
you have to be a few times me in and
that's awesome
there's a lot of people have approached
just since we opened his mind up to
jointly as partners and because we know
we wanted to a thousand units so we're
literally we're thinking when we need to
tell other people to get their yeah
we're not gonna get there if nothing is
even if they're a dick then they could
put the money but then they'd win your
neck every Tuesday yeah yeah you don't
want to do realistic
rotation yeah forget it I'll get the
maid from the bank back yeah yeah yeah
okay
so what sort of projects then would you
would you do rockin would you give you
see working mine Doncaster and what sort
of figures what the thing that we're
doing in linker
yeah there's we've priced in a few hours
aren't we in Doncaster you'll built the
few we've built one of your own
endeavors I've built a bill for in
Doncaster the air bit laughs you look
quite a while I was really bored unique
no don't custom bother me I'm more
Sheffield and Barnsley and rod Romano
all the Mo's I don't care too much about
where the area is yeah if it was
Sheffield yeah arms like yeah well
that's the figure though I know some
cracking plots for sailing around there
and the airline for sale code but it's
not on market it's not unlike think you
said 250 I'm not sure I'd have to find
out again and that's got you know me
find in which you find it is your love
we have ours Association a love so I
want them 15% yield so I know you are oh
I'm amber I love them 15 thing we like
them because sweetie you seem to buy a
portfolio off them as well and that's
what we're doing so you got boring give
me give me an example don't give me okay
toast of the year so best but well last
four were just done 132 750 we bought
for from 650 to 750 we spent 25 grand on
them here we get in what rent now we
about 22 grouse on and go about it sorry
132 or 750 for one of the house for out
of the floor for the floor and what
we've got to do is because obviously
spine aligner get some photos under 50
under 50 Kate Arden Tino you paged you
pin money what they've done is we've
done it was crucial broken they've been
a breach - laughs okay so literally they
group them together which quite under
eros
be able to leverage their money and me
about earlier because I guess that 130
7/4
what's that like it's like 30 grand
it's like these are the hours we're
finding could that one it's not good no
but did you nominate yourself oh no
that's problem he's asleep no that one's
not that's yeah that's some lightbulbs
that one that's a girl thought that idea
that's good shot when I got up and home
yeah and they're just like disgusting on
the inside yeah well that one a golf
thought we just got actually nice and
science degree why I new kitchen but
it's not bit very far when y'all just
got my firm star lies part you know
whatever that you know boy in
probabilities were like 25 grounds and
then spending what like fourth element
no no you spent 25 grand the north for
Falls because we've been doing at the
cost of sends work and a lot you feel
pretty excited excited you building
units of pain you've got a big site
about everything you do that because
it's my word hold on hold on you buying
it for 25 grand then you spend in what
like six seven grand then do it yeah
it's not yeah and then and then it's
it's it's worth what's the value then on
a single unit about five year so what I
into I'm just with them do you follow
its again yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
what we're just doing now have values
come last waves and then for the lot of
20 grams yeah paid 30 for that so this
they've got always money back out what
my point for it is deposit with that's a
three-bed life why are you winning at
this game all the way you're winning you
because you're builders and you can
build it really cheap because most
people if they bought up 25 grams but
get build with the Builder were below
all 20 grams
refurb but what it wouldn't be it
wouldn't if you bought that for 25 and
you spent 20 20 on it this is the view
and this is why I don't like to tell you
too much better see Asian yeah they're
all pretty good Nick so the roofs are
okay the windows rock the electric
socket
they've all got decent boxes in all most
of our boilers so did you find him
the consortium and then also what you're
saying is because the Housing
Association the tenants have made it
look really ugly on the inside but
actually yes yes pictures when we've
Adam I think I think one of the album's
we actually spent about 15k on just one
so you can imagine we did the other
three for like 15 so that's basically
just we stick a magnet kitchen in LA
metro tiles tiding or new kitchens New
Balance kitchen to tune after and now
less we've paid from wheelers
macrophylla we paid magnets at Langner
they're cheap what we tend to do is in
other rental number for used to buy
Allen's contract kitchens so you can buy
16 units and because we've got a big
commercial unit down the area and then a
warm we'd store it so with then we make
a kitchen out of it all so that means
it's pretty cool so rather than games
either in and paying for all that
shortage of this if you have the money
could you just buy like yes no no no no
it's none of our said about them because
literally the house associations now not
been do any up any off-market deals on
these no sauce things through another
guy yeah that says Lindley won but we
paid 22 an hour and that's what we've
just spent - enough done money and 500
were 500 pounder that was it selective
license or that were 22 and after lot to
pay - enough expecting off-brand in
their 500 was selective license
included and that would rent to that win
three weeks got far and how much is it
worth what you've been the work that
4045 people on the street they've been
auction at minute about the between 35
and 4 Congrats man you guys do really
well you found you you found your niche
if you like a fictitious case study then
it works do deal so let's say you found
a deal I mean do you want are you more
interested in the biggest of a lobster
war or are you interested do drop
anything we win if we do whatever it was
it's just a refurb or it's a new bill or
to flip whatever we're interested in
whatever yeah an idea we were so we've
got as bombers that we're gonna move
with the combining together to go big
yeah so literally we were also doing
that with property now so yeah we was
the own are we investors recover the
farm which father and the house at shy
ropes worked for 75 grand what had
turning to tall flats and shadows was a
really nice desirable area 75 grand
that's all for right put it on what's up
so 75 grand house and the number tree
photo did turn into tall flats the big
in the big it's hard to say but the
terrace houses over the role of fetching
120 yeah so that's at 75 just had a new
roof on that I find that bizarre but
I'll get them details we're not we can't
have a better
you can't win a project and start
charging top end money is equal partners
kind of you've got to have a bitter the
fact that you're doing the work it comes
and we're sourcing them as well aren't
they yeah so then he's financing the the
work at cost of the of the research now
just now just say the police'll thing
because it seemed we're financing
development are you say you're doing
financing the we're doing we're doing
the refurbs of self at a cost to all 450
grams now and then the cost of the
reefer that cost 450 grams yes to say
you he would bother the hoodlum 50 run
down and then you would then put 50
grand down yeah yeah and then you go
50/50 on the profits yeah but because
you you're such you're so good at doing
it cheap that's good sometimes you can
put down very little money yeah okay
that makes sense and then from from from
Johnson or for my point of view you're
not thinking oh you know that are they
actually charge them for the work
because your pay for anyone yeah that's
it okay if we did a new build project
how would that work because the cost for
that would be quite big wouldn't it yeah
the thing is it's yeah well you get it's
basically obviously getting us don't you
to do a price fascicle yeah and then you
can work back from it just your labor
costs do it that way can't you it's it's
you like say yours you'd get us to price
to build old town which it's going to
cost yeah and then we'd we'd look at it
and so right well we can do it say it
with 200 grand to build them on qsys
thing we looking so where we can make
that work it ones in 20 grand that's it
do it that way so you know on the state
not build that's what makes is are more
valuable so obviously you gdv small
savings a lot just a lot more meat on
the bone just a minute split let's just
say that you found something in
Doncaster all rather more Sheffield that
was the same as my Lincoln deal yeah so
you saw Peter land and you you could buy
the 330 yeah you could build six houses
on there and then you knew that the end
value was one point three five million
how would you put that forward to me
that minute is is not something we've
ever done so like super caught things so
well the thing is that something we this
is a new thing for us with joint
ventures so we've never done it so it's
like don't know what's right way or
wrong way
nothing is but profits while we probably
give them a really good deal because
it's lie we still believe we're still
lied we have to participate with not
only knowledge and skill I liked it they
were pretty much on the same page but
like what's fair yeah yeah gotcha you
know it's kind of obvious what's fair
isn't if one person's putting it all the
money all the money for the perks price
yeah and in one person's finding him is
doing all the work yeah this is real
macho exactly 50/50 on the properties is
pretty fair yeah yeah so what I'm
suggesting would be is probably though
you guys send something that really
thinks really good to me well there's a
particular plant mini what I we've we've
had this farm this Bowling Green yeah I
couldn't negotiate its deal but it means
buying it I got development yeah I don't
think it struggle gdb on that I probably
about what do we say it were that we're
at for 14 units or 16 oh it's 12 it and
12 it comfortable yeah how about 2.2 yes
well that was tight there yes it's like
literally semies you know the townhouses
literally I've got one a minute and
Nick's got one so we're not layout as
well it works really well it's like it's
really good for like people moving up so
a bigger home and people horse or
downsize and so I'm quite glad that
formula is in literal that had the build
itself it works really well I can find
it on would you want to buy with
planning or would you want to get
throwing up personally wheels is I'd
like to buy it with planning because
it's a silly I'm very risk-averse as
you're unfamiliar it's already something
up I don't like to take too many risks
yeah especially with for me new bill
it's like I've had another crash
tomorrow and we've all heard a lie we've
got for up to these days what are your
thought will develop and finance already
ambassador in its to reach yeah that's
me I like to pretend I don't like to put
my family basically it's the local
Bowling Green's wasteland at the back
there's two parties only parish council
on the land of the back and what I call
him John John John owns our for the land
so we said we've been approached them
both yeah we've been to parish councils
said look in Bowling Green
you can put you a bit to a car park on
and it takes all traffic off that road
which is getting a lot of complaints
about sit helps council with planning if
you lose on that in game itself tax also
but from a train swing without as well
as this one that's any problem check
killed that on board of Sheffield the
problem very close to my office that I
know I know very well we're doing a deal
where as literally we give like so much
the profits to profit share and so much
to the guy but I think if we were to go
in and say right so you are I like even
this much of the land going on your
expertise if you could think say yeah we
do you know what it's a nice size we
know the site would work with
motorsports of council as well they they
purposely they couldn't see a problem on
there but because we've never it's not
my money you know means you start off we
it's it's something we've never like
push forward and that's what we do we
find all this court stuff but then it's
like you limit to the game you lie yeah
well let me call it yeah if it were our
business and it work well so our Armonia
would have already cigar I tell you what
with year 150 ground between your foot
long and their blood snatch and off and
that makes them them their plots then
really really helpful just saw the
actual and value on each other mouth and
you probably look at about ones in that
grand each unit there's no yeah mega
yeah and we probably would get planning
yeah can you don't speak to the
counseling and they get a bit of a
theater person yeah you see you probably
are up because what's doing those
release in the amount of traffic for the
ball in green on the show we can know
that look a lot older than 50 groans I
don't see what happens then we just sell
the land I think if it could be cheeky
I've like a couple hundred grand eleven
it could be email outlet potential I say
get permitted development awesome Oh Oh
Nikolas yeah couldn't do yeah it's a
nice piece of London which is a good
cloth it is a little flock as far as we
got him wearing a lie how much trekking
you'd be able to build each house for
what did we work that are we did it on
this Johnny 90 but knife no a bit more
in there aren't there bit bigger by
hundred and hundred telling something
yes 198 198 so that really interested
[Laughter]
see because we've got the architect
agent we saw him just says right this is
real and we went on Google Earth did all
these things and then says yeah I can
get you 12 on there so that's when we
went a flourish Council says come with
short tried saw some how to put 12 hours
on what do you want to give us your land
just said well when they're not with the
greedy it because it's two different
parties so because one of them's my
flight mechanic friend and and then
there's the council but I think my
mechanic friends being a bit greedy and
what II think to do what the profit
share I think everything to the ones
worth millions so now I mean obviously
the first oil engaging conversation
while you Jeannie we could be this and
obviously I think that's gonna be all
this so I think it's got a bit greedy on
thinking but who's this person this is
this is the the my friend or the Canada
mechanic who's a potential to adventure
partner yeh could be yeah what I
probably want to do it and go around
more ducks are we reacted in our meet
and we aren't
I've worked much rather Lee would you
know what this is how much we're hot on
table so you know let me feel and I
thinking but I yeah yeah we don't want
him as a partner he lands part of the
Elms part on it in parish council with
other party over when there's problems
is better because when you solve the
problems you get more than exactly
you don't have problems of solution it's
already got planning permission it's
really neat nice and tidy but you don't
make as much yeah yeah that's it
someone's very thought you know what the
that the actual land volumes worth yeah
and also if you if your lands mean if
you lands contaminated with depending
what's been on you can get one during
the 10 percent back it cost to clean it
if he wants contaminated and it costs
hundred grand you'll get Wonderland ten
grand Mike fifteen actually see we're
not we just yeah we've not wait well
that many I've got a lot of knotweed up
backer a commercial so literally I'm
just swapping banks at minute to get rid
of our HMO the deal so to get that one
encumbered so soon as I do that I'm
going to make a claim of a railway
itself what do you guys think the
implications are bricked it won't they I
won't worry too much you I felt happens
it's gonna be 1518 mobsters anyway into
so just need there's me personally it
could be good it's good in one aspect
for an investor cause you can won by a
lot of cheap Al's gonna drop there's in
like development that's what I don't
want sensor especially I'm doing new
developments cuz you never know I've
been there last thing you want to be
doing especially be using your own money
as big I don't know a million two
million pounds for development and then
you mean you see a tips and crash you
lie it's like oh we're gonna dip a bit
whenever we come out on it and then it's
just gonna go back up again telling
recession for any eight for ages so
they're gonna blame we're gonna blame
next recession on brakes to Kenya yeah
so yeah it said once established with 12
years
there are views on the regs always think
that it depends if we get a deal or not
yeah why do you think we'll get a deal
on up oh I think we'll walk over deal at
me - yeah and I think that prices will
drop quite a bit yeah much don't think
they will so much up north no mom this
is nothing but I think about nor
properties have pretty much gone down
yeah I know Sheffield's beginning to
bars a bit now yeah but like London's
already dropped our young man I mean
she's like Birmingham yeah yeah big sis
so it's something that I'd watch balance
and like yeah I know be worried not
worried but if I'm doing if we're doing
blood developments yeah we lines won't
be able to sell properties and values
and stuff like that I just think you
just need to be aware of yeah gotcha
yeah yeah so I think I think then the
conclusion kind of move up with eBay if
you put some get some properties and
then let me know what you want that you
think all this could be a good one what
do you reckon and then I'll probably get
a give a proposal likewise if you see
anything like rounded with inline for
instance 30 minutes or whatever to this
so there's an area
so we're a bit that I'm near and down
the middle wall so literal anyway the I
finished converging you see anything
cool like that you know I mean come and
see us and we'll have another chat and
we're sure we've been doing it together
so we're in Doncaster do obvious Samuel
and Amanda come really good on picture
and on video but actually in real life
the tremendous people
really aspire to be like them and what
they're doing with proper Tippin is
brilliant
so yes Nash you're working with all that
passionate people and property thought
let's see what the next move is for us
all at the good yeah we're great showing
him around some projects we've gone to
at moment showing around a new build
site talked about their projects great
talking about that to come to an HTML
we're working on as well asked a bit of
advice on things and the other
down-to-earth people great yeah we'd
love to work with Samuel on some
projects awfully we've got a few in the
pipeline real soon okay Louie yeah great
see not really nice guys definitely very
knowledgeable about the area and been in
the trade a very long time so I've told
them to just send me some proposals
across ie some projects and then I'll
put together a joint venture proposal
and let's see what happens so that's not
the very first step because sometimes
it's easy you know you see me guys doing
big projects and development stuff but
this is how it gets started this is all
the foundational work you need when you
build a house you need foundation but
when you set up a deal
you need foundation of a deal and this
is all the stuff that people don't
usually say so I hope you found it
helpful comment below let us know your
thoughts let me know what you learned
and I'll see you next time
you